it is a go for CCSD superintendent Dr  Jesus Jara today the School Board of  Trustees passed Jar's new agreement  during a work session this follows last  week's review of the superintendent  where he received an A in the annual  evaluation  in the meeting Jara says he is committed  to continue to work to improve our  school system and that the focus should  be on the classrooms and students  I know we say this to our schools to our  teachers  the most important place is not my  office not this seat it's a classroom  and we have done some good work as a  board  the New Deal includes a 75 000 annual  raise increasing salary to start at 395  000 a year it would run through 2026.